The Joe Rogan Experience because there's
a whole another level of training to
Wu-Tang like if you specifically put
Wu-Tang on to train yeah like I kind of
get your mentality in that that internal
yeah you know feeling that you get
because yeah that's one of my not my
last fight but the fight before I walked
out to protect your neck yes and like
that just that mentality like yeah the
beat and the drums yeah you just feel
like this this I don't know it's like a
badass martial arts so we're like a
street martial artist well we drive to
shows like when we leave the hotel and
then we go to the arena when whenever
I'm doing comedy we listen to protection
act that's the first thing we listen to
we get in the car either gravel pit or
protect your neck a gravel Pit's crazy
right yeah
it's just I get it man that era of
hip-hop to me is just like I mean
obviously I'm old so like that era was
when I was young and it was like when I
was really getting into hip-hop but
there's something about that era of
hip-hop because it was hip-hop was only
a couple of decades old then yep you
know really didn't I mean Sugarhill Gang
was like what
1979 78 like when when was um Rapper's
Delight who I mean way before my time I
was born 90. so like I think it was like
78 or 79. it could have been remember it
could have been do you know
okay so yeah so that's that's when rap
was essentially modern rap was
essentially born and then you know 10
years later 15 years later you know you
got cool G Rap and DJ Polo you got all
those 90s hip-hop guys yep you know
correct that's officially released on
September 16th 1975. there you go did
you get to see the uh Wu-Tang Saga at
all on Hulu no Joe okay you gotta watch
it oh my God yeah okay I hadn't been
excited about a show in a long time and
I saw the Wu-Tang Saga and some people
have certain you know whatever their
opinions on it but I think to be able to
see
the background of every single member of
Wu-Tang right so it follows the like
each character individually and how they
all came together and
um Ashton Sanders Saunders who plays the
the Rizza and just there's a scene in
season two where he's sampling the music
and
it takes him into this like all black
room where
the I can't even remember the uh the
group that it that that he was sampling
but they pop up and they're each playing
their instruments and then like as he
turns it down on the keyboard or on you
know as he turns it down on the board
then like the guy's still singing But
like you can't hear him anymore
apparently he was on set for for a lot
of the like scenes and stuff just kind
of overseeing everything or giving his
input on like you know this is how it is
but yeah being someone who loves to make
music and produce beats and stuff it
when I saw that scene like I had to
rewind it I had to replay it because I'm
like yeah exactly you when you're
listening when you're trying to create
music and maybe if you're sampling you
might just hear the guitar and you don't
want the drums or you don't want this
thing so you like turn that down and
you're like Ah that's the feeling that I
want to sample so when I saw that I mean
that was season two but I was already
sold on the show before you know how
many seasons are there
I think only two and the third is coming
yeah the third one's coming out the
interesting thing about hip-hop is that
it was the first musical genre at least
a popular musical genre that sampled
stuff
like in that they and they it what you
know it made the songs more interesting
because you heard a little bit of an old
song in there and you're like oh I
remember that beat but then it's all
these new lyrics over that beat that
changes what that beat is and it's like
there was this
you know there was like a lot of debate
in the early days of sampling like is
this stealing like what is this it's
like no because the other song still
exists and it's obvious that this is a
piece of that other song but it you know
like but it enhances new music yeah
exactly it's a totally different thing
like taking little pieces of stuff and
combining it together
personally as as a it's a uh it's an
appreciation yes right it's like someone
created this masterpiece already and I
took my favorite part from it and maybe
just looped it or sped it up yeah and
then kind of made a version of it not to
like compete with yeah this other song
but it's like an appreciation like thank
you you've just made this amazing you
know piece of music that I can now
listen to on repeat or listen to in a
way that you know translates to me in a
certain way and to Millions more I don't
know I don't see any problem with it I
think it's cool yeah it's not like
they're pretending they didn't do that
you know what I mean like stealing is
like there's there's there's been bands
that have gotten in trouble because they
have a rift that sounds exactly like an
old riff that's on a record and they
don't give the other band credit it's
not a sample they're just trying to copy
it and then they wind up losing all the
royalties well you know that's the
business of the business yeah you got to
get your cut too though right you can't
be mad at the other guy that music
business is a weird business you know
like guys who are in a band together the
band can be massive but two guys are
like the head guys in the band and they
make all the money yeah and then the
other guys get pissed you know yeah I
mean kind of going back to Wu-Tang I
feel like that there was a little a
little bit of that wasn't you know yeah
there were any members in Wu-Tang at one
point in time right yeah absolutely but
I think one of the things was
um the guys didn't really understand the
music business Rizza was like the brains
behind it he was the one who like you
know had all of the kind of like
business decisions and like hey I need
you guys to sign this I need you guys to
sign these contracts so we can get this
money to make this music and
um you know they kind of try trusted him
and and did it and uh I guess it just it
didn't end up really being like a good
deal for everybody
um they go over it a little bit in the
show but I think there's another
documentary that kind of goes a little
bit more in depth you know with all that
stuff but yeah man this is dirty yeah
business is dirty it's a dirty game
business uh yes it is with so many
people and so many different you know
yeah man we all got to get paid yeah
that's just the fact that they brought
those dudes together though is so
interesting that the Wu-Tang Clan Has
existed at all and it's so iconic
you know like Wu-Tang is probably the
most iconic hip-hop band of all time
yeah I mean off the top of my head I
really can't think of someone else to
that to compare that doesn't No One
Compares it's a different thing yeah
like Wu-Tang is like a mindset yeah like
like when Dave Chappelle says Wutang is
a punchline sometimes Michael says
[Laughter]
you can't use any other band yeah you
really can't yeah you really can't and
they're I mean they're they're they're
there's logo their symbol they're known
everywhere you can go to you know
Jakarta Indonesia and it's like they
know who Wu-Tang is or they've seen the
symbol or something and the people in it
vary so while you got Old Dirty Bastard
who was just [ __ ] crazy yep and then
you got the Giza who's like he's an
elite chess player yeah and I think he's
done like TED talks and [ __ ] no the guys
is a genius yeah like a legitimate
genius is a genius yeah I think he
actually he studied and has a degree in
something like very yeah something
physics yeah I think he has like a
Physics degree or something like that
yeah the guy the guys what was his Ted
Talk see if you can find out what the
jizz's Ted Talk is but because I
guarantee he did a TED Talk yeah look at
that the genius of science the Giza and
the science genius at tedx teen yeah I
mean what the [ __ ] man
it's incredible yeah I mean when you
listen to some of his bars you're like
wow exactly how do you yeah put those
things together that's the other thing
about 90s hip-hop and like that era and
Wu-Tang Clan in particular like the
lyrics were so good there was you would
hear lyrics and you would just go oh
[ __ ] like how did you put those together
yeah to make that yeah you know scenario
happened and yeah lyrics to me are
everything I mean the beat is everything
too I mean it's all together obviously
but it's like man just something about
like sharp lyrics it's it's exciting